okay hey everyone and let's begin thank
you for coming to the stock sorry for
being a little late uh but let's move on
now my name is Adam furmanek and for the
next one hour we are going to talk a
little bit about locks and they are
tricky so we are going to see
um some theory of concurrency
parallelism and how it's used throughout
the computer science we are also to see
going to see multiple practical examples
of where locks might be hidden from you
where logs are like stored where they
are used which mechanisms in the
operating system and the cloud in the
databases use them and where they might
be
hidden from us but yet still affecting
our code base so that's the plan for the
next hour the QR code points you to the
slide that will be available at the very
end as well so feel free to to download
that and before moving on couple words
about me I'm a software engineer for
over a decade now working recently a lot
with machine learning also and author of
these two books one of them being
about.net internals the other one being
about maths so feel free to take a look
at and and also visit my blog if you are
interested in like computer science in
general.net jvm internals some math some
other stuff dropping a line in my
Twitter whatever works for you
and being that set let's begin so the
agenda for today's talk is we're going
to start with some general concepts so
we want to understand the Locking
concurrency parallelism set some
definitions straight and all that stuff
see the basic concurrency Primitives we
can use then we'll focus on some real
life examples like inside the operating
system maybe inside the databases you
use maybe in the languages we are using
a real quick row of hands how many of
you use dotnet okay majority of the room
that's good I'll be showing examples
mostly in.net however they are
applicable to nearly any language you
might be using so feel free to
generalize those and think about how
they can apply to other languages very
similar to data like Java or maybe a
little more for friends like python or
maybe Husker or other things you might
be using ultimately we'll go through
some algorithms and end up with custom
implementation so we'll see one example
of a very nice lock which I'm using in
production for some time showing how we
can solve a particular problem which
seems to be super trivial to solve but
our operating systems do not solve that
unfortunately so let's begin so general
concepts first thing let's get some
definitions straight okay so concurrency
and parallelism they are often mixed up
but they are actually two completely
different concepts right concurrency is
about being able to cut your application
in parts and be able to execute those
parts in basically any order and it does
not apply to your application only this
applies to everything you're running on
a single machine or maybe on multiple
machines or maybe on multiple computers
around the planet right if we are
talking about one single particular
workflow we want to cut it in pieces and
execute those pieces out of order so the
the most important or the most common
example we can think of is how we are
actually dealing with like multiple
applications running on one single CPU
right what do we do we do some code Type
sharing right so we let one app run for
like couple of milliseconds then we
pause it we run another app etc etc so
this concept of concurrency is actually
coming straight down to like resource
access sharing resources and this
resource can be of multiple forms this
could be for instance CPU top Utah this
could be an
critical section this could be an access
to memory or multiple other things we
can think of but generally concurrency
is about controlling and access to some
particular specific resource parallelism
on the other hand is about being able to
run multiple things at the same time in
parallel we are not cheating we are not
pretending that we run multiple
applications on one CPU and they run
like parallel even though we we juggle
them constantly we actually have
physical ability to run multiple things
at once meaning that most likely we need
to have multiple cores multiple CPUs or
maybe multiple machines okay and the
interesting part about that is you can
actually get a mix of these two in any
way you wish you may have application
which is like parallel but not
concurrent something which is a bit
problematic when we think about that but
generally for every single like mix of
those we can get an example for instance
concurrent parallel this is the thing
which we are typically used to nowadays
right we have multiple cores in our
computers multiple applications are
running at the same time multiple
threads are executing and yet inside our
single application we sometimes need to
make sure that we execute things like
with critical sections so we lock access
to a resource and still we have both
concurrency and parallelism
non-concurrent and non-parallel systems
are long gone they were available like
60 years ago when we had batch modes
batch systems so the only thing we had
is we were putting in some card like
punch card with the source code and it
was executed like straight from top down
to bottom okay that was it we couldn't
stop it we couldn't pause it I mean the
cute computer couldn't pause itself to
run some other application and this is
something we could also see in like very
early days of Dos operating system hands
up if you ever use dos NEOS oh yeah
there are some dinosaurs in the room
hello to all of you generally it allowed
for something which was like upper mode
extended mode there are multiple names
of that for that right but you have like
a limited amount of memory for which you
could put another kind of application
which was like running in the background
right so it tried to be concurrent in
the sense that there were two things
allowed to run in a concurrently but
still it was more of this this batch
mode thingy however then we get
something which is not concurrent and
parallel what is that this is something
that we are for instance running in our
CPUs we have vectored instructions right
we have bit level parallelism right so
what we do is we can have a CPU
instruction which adds multiple integers
at once so pairs of integers right so it
operates on something like 256 bits or
whatever else bigger values maybe and it
just adds them independently from each
other but still in parallel does that
like in one go and the other thing is
well concurrent not parallel one CPU and
we are doing context switching over and
over again so those are examples of any
mix of these two we can have now the
other big area when it comes to
concurrency locking and all that stuff
is shared memory versus message passing
charging memory is when well multiple
cores or multiple machines physically
access exactly the same part of the
memory and we are talking physical
memory here right and this thingy means
that both of them want to access the
same literal thing so they need to
control how they are doing that so they
do not break the state this is something
we typically cannot use between machines
well because they they probably most of
the times have their own independent
memory sometimes even with one machine
when we are talking about the Numa
non-uniform memory access it may be that
multiple cores are trying to access the
same memory even though physically
there's like distant to each other but
this is a bit different typically shared
memory is just used within one single
machine and this is where we are dealing
with that it requires some critical
sections some controlling how we access
that memory but the advantage of that is
generally this is this thing is
generally faster than message passing
okay obviously that's not a benchmark
your mileage may vary but however the
general rule of thumb is this should be
faster message passing on the other hand
is when we are just sending messages
between like two whatever components we
can think of those could be threats and
those could be processes with IPC
interprocess communication those could
be nodes across the world that could be
internet connection whatever else this
requires some way of communication most
likely this is like wire with sockets
however this is also this could be also
like common storage or maybe message
queue service bus yada yada we can
obviously use this in multiple scenarios
typically this is slower but the
ultimate part is that this message
passing allows us to control things a
little easier when we are talking about
us being programmers how do we control
all these things the message passing
tends to be easier to control so this is
generally something we probably or at
least multiple languages and
Technologies like pushes nowadays that
we want to go to the message passing
interface instead of having this certain
memory but it's slower so keep that in
mind if you're writing high performance
code
and now we will be focusing on
or if we are trying to do something
without logs then we may have multiple
issues now the question is why do we
even need locks what can go wrong and
the frame like most important parts of
framework is important like Concepts
which can go wrong are here on the slide
and first one being like lost right this
is probably also in the University you
try to add some money use and transfer
between banking accounts yeah cliche
typical example right so what we do is
we actually have two operations which
for us programmers seem to be just like
one single Atomic right we represent
this in the code AS variable plus plus
okay just line one line of code seems to
be one operation but under the hood
actually it's two different operations
or actually three of them we read the
memory we increment it in like register
CP registers and then we write it back
to the RAM memory right and this can go
wrong because once we read something the
other thread also reads the same value
we both increase and try writing the
value bank one right is lost okay this
is the typical example of what can go
wrong but the others the other one is
word tearing this is something when we
our computers in order to be fast they
want to work on like bigger amount of
data they do not work on particular bits
what they want to do is they want to
work on things like integer which is
32-bit long okay typically or long value
which is 64-bit long actually we should
be talking about octets not not like
bytes so this is 64 bits meaning eight
octets and generally this is how CPU
work nowadays okay but what happens if
you would like to you know toggle just
one bit inside the integer what happens
if we allow multiple threads to toggle
different bits inside the same integer
well we get the thing which is called
word tearing and this means that we are
trying to modify just one piece of this
integer but we need to write actually a
whole lot of it like all 32 bits or 64
bits or whatever else okay and this
means that by doing that if we do not
control our access correctly then we may
be overriding changes which someone else
done in different parts of the of this
integer okay so this is worth tearing so
this is when we are trying to access
like a very little portion of bigger
data structure and the other one is
quite the opposite we are trying to
access much bigger structure but we can
only write a part of it at the same time
like in atomicity okay when we are
talking about having atomic structures
which are like one kilobyte long we
would need to be writing every single
integer of it and obviously this may
break so how can we do with that and
this is where we go to the thing which
is called critical section and critical
section is a code which can be executed
by one execution unit at a time and
normal words meaning that we have one
for which we have part of the code which
if threat only one fret can execute at
the time and this was a super important
problem in early days of computer
science it's pretty common for us
nowadays because we first know how to
solve it and have all the tools for
solving it but when the computers
emerged it wasn't that trivial to solve
it because we just didn't know what to
do but still there are multiple issues
we may not be thinking of but they are
still appearing today what happens if
you are running your critical section in
your social language or whatever else
and you just die in the middle like you
have 10 line of codes inside the lock
and what happens if someone stops you in
the middle after Fifth Line okay how can
you proceed and this is something
computer science is not solving for us
because that's a business problem
actually we need to understand whether
it's safe to proceed because we don't
know whether we are in a consistent
State whether we broke we broke some
data structures or not whether it be
broke transactions or not and computer
science won't just solve that there is
not no structure like log business
process make sure customers are happy
that's enough not something like this
right but we need to make sure we are
doing that and this is why logs are
tricky because locking a part of the
code well is super trivial nowadays look
keyword in C sharp synchronizing Java
Bank it just works right but what
happens when things go wrong and this is
what will be discussing uh after we
figure out how to actually do this
locking so we'll go through a couple of
basic primitive concurrency mechanisms
really quick to understand what we are
dealing with and the first thing is
called mutex the name comes from Mutual
exclusion and uh depending on whether we
are dealing with like single CPU system
multiple CPU systems this can be
implemented like with disabling Hardware
interrupts or maybe synchronizing CPUs
or maybe just with support on the of the
CPU special instructions for locking so
your CPU to implement basically a mutex
or to allow you to implement a mutex
actually or you your CPUs they need to
provide some physical machine
instructions for locking something and
there's something in early days was
typically uh like a bus address so you
had bus connecting components of your
computer and the CPU was locking a
particular set of bits on this bus
addressing nowadays it's a little
different but still goes down to the
same concept we are locking a memory
address and we are doing that with the
help of CPU so now CPU needs to be our
of your login how CPUs Implement that we
won't be getting that low level today
but in for us enough is that we need to
have the CPU uh CPU support for that
typically we just use those things from
the operating system meaning that
operating system provides us some way of
having having mutex right it may be even
that this mutex is optimized for user
mode kernel mode and multiple other
scenarios but generally we just rely on
things which are provided by the
operating system so if Windows if you
are running on Windows and you do use
any mutex or critical section
actually.net uses the same mechans which
are provided by the OS itself the other
mechanism oh when it comes to the API
those are the the names of the functions
we are just using in.net is just mutex
the other mechanism which is pretty
common is counting semaphore so we want
to generalize the idea of controlling
access to something previously we were
just making sure that only one fret can
access the critical section now we want
to allow potentially multiple threads
but limited number of them so we want to
count how many Frets can enter the
critical section and this is called uh
called a counting semaphore and Counting
SEMA for primitive provides two
operations V and K and their names come
from Dutch so this is very Hogan and pro
Baron so they either increase or
decrease the counter and there is one
pretty common uh interview question you
may have I have heard that or maybe ask
yourselves is what's the difference
between like mutex and between
accounting semaphore which counts only
zero and one so allows just one thread
to enter the critical section and we
call that SEMA for a binary semaphore so
what's the difference there are actually
multiple of those even though they do
not seem to be like that obvious first
thing is like generally mutex
shares and trucks the ownership meaning
that mutex knows who took it who locked
it who owns the mutex currently and who
in this particular case means which
thread running in the operating system
okay semaphore doesn't dug it like
semaphore doesn't share it doesn't track
the ownership it just blindly increases
or decreases the counter okay that's it
and this poses multiple issues when we
are talking about our thread dying in
the middle of critical section because
if we are protecting a critical section
with mutex and the threat dies then you
know that the critical section is now
abandoned there is no thread running
inside because well the threat died but
if you are doing that with semaphore
then you don't know whether critical
section is abandoned or not similarly
you can text take mutex recursively if
you have a recursive function and you
are doing lock something inside this
function then you can do it many times
you can do it recursively with mutex you
can't do that with semaphore because
well semaphore doesn't know it is you
who is holding the semaphore because it
just counts right similarly this also
blocks the application from terminating
for instance if we have a critical
section and we know someone is there
then the this mutex can blocks or stop
the application from terminating we
cannot do that with semaphores we cannot
control priorities because we don't know
who holds that right so we just know
someone might be there but we have no
sure we are not sure about that and
another thing the most important one is
actually if you are trying to take a
mutex like or use a lock keyword in in
c-sharp or just do mutex the Loca choir
or whatever and the threat owning it
dies then you are notified about that
right.net froze an exception of UK there
was an abandoned mutex so feel free to
take it but you need to know whether the
data structures are Mouse incorrect
State okay with semaphore for Freight
dice then bang you're done SEMA 4 just
won't let you know that that it's been
abandoned so generally a rule of thumb
is if you are using semaphores be
careful because they may be way harder
to use than it's they seem to be
obviously some API and one interesting
thing about semaforce.net provides
actually two implementations of them one
of them the semaphore is backed by the
operating system construct so it's
typically slower because it goes through
the kernel mode switch from user lens to
Kernel land Etc some are for slim try
fixing that or maybe improving on that a
little bit by also doing a spin looping
so before entering the kernel mode Auto
does is it first tries to spin for a
little and then it makes it a little
faster okay so generally the
recommendation is if you generally you
should know what you're doing when you
are using locking Primitives but
recommendation might be that consider
SEMA for slim instead of the semaphore
and now we are actually entering a very
interesting world how should we tag a
concurrency primitive okay how should we
lock it and there are two typical
approaches first of them is go to sleep
so ask the operating system hey I'd like
to take this a concurrency primitive I'd
like to acquire it but it's being taken
now I'm going to sleep please do wake me
up when it's ready okay so operating
system will keep the track of of the
concurrency primitive for you and will
wake you up when it's available and
you'll be given this lock or whatever
else right however this is expensive
because operating system needs to take
care of that expensive as in transition
from user mode to the kernel mode takes
a significant amount of time significant
number of milliseconds so generally if
we are doing this hundreds or thousands
of time a second then generally it will
it will hit us it's like a performance
hit and more importantly but this is
something for operating system
implementation and writing drivers and
all that stuff we can't sleep in all
circumstances we can't sleep for
instance if we are writing driver kernel
drivers because well operating system
cannot just go to sleep some or in all
the cases so this is something we'll
need to think about that but that's a
whole different story the other approach
is let's just do a spin weight so we
might want to hog the CPU so we will be
constantly checking hey log are you
available to be acquired I am not okay
I'll sleep for a second just wait or
maybe I'm just looping without sleeping
okay and then you hear your fans going
on your computer becomes loud your CPU
spikes up and you're just doing that
over and over again okay so this is the
so-called spin weighting it's generally
something we should avoid but still if
you are spinning for like short amount
of time for instance a couple of
milliseconds because we know that the
the lock or the concurrency primitive we
are using is going to be released very
soon then it's actually pretty often
used and for instance your Google Chrome
browser ever use Google Chrome and your
laptop was like crazy uh well Google
Chrome implemented their own spin locks
and their own concurrency Primitives and
all that stuff under the hood running in
user mode they claim it's much faster
but maybe it's the cost of your fans
going bus as well so generally computers
do that multiple upper applications are
doing that and this is sometimes in
kernel programming this is the only
thing we can actually do but generally
we probably want to avoid that when we
are writing just a regular business line
of business applications
the other interesting
um concurrency primitive is called
monitor so what do we do is we always or
pretty often we have this um this
pattern that we would like to lock some
primitive like mutex then check some
condition hey is it safe to proceed
because I want to do something specific
and if it's not then what do I want to
do well I want to release this mutex and
wait for a bit and then try again if the
condition is now true okay so what do I
do well I just spin in the loop I spin
in the loop and the question is how do I
do that well do I exit the log and take
a sleep do I spin weight for a couple of
minutes and all that stuff and generally
the solution for that is the monitor
with condition variable so monitor with
condition variable is a concept which
does exactly this code under the hood
for you but takes care of the operating
system so in this point in this if
condition do work sorry in the other and
this Branch else loop again operating
system would put us to sleep and wait
for the condition condition to be true
and then wake up us again and this is
another primitive we should be using so
if we see p pattern like this then let's
just go for it
and obviously some API for that now the
important thing how we are using that in
dotnet the API for that is Monitor pulls
plus monitor weight if we are doing that
it's super crucial and there's a source
of common bugs that we are trying to do
lock sync and then we are doing monitor
weight inside this if Branch okay and
the thing here is this should never be
if because someone might call monitor
pulls all or maybe a driver might wake
you up or maybe operating system might
wake your thread so this is called a
spurious wake up meaning that even
though you went to sleep in this monitor
wait line some think woke you up before
this condition was true so before you
could safely proceed so what you need to
do is instead of having F here you need
to have a while and you might go to
sleep multiple times
uh that's it for like the most basic uh
Primitives now we are talking about
entering the word how do we synchronize
across multiple applications multiple
computers multiple nodes across the
world so we have this distinction
between local Primitives like mutex
which is held only in the user land and
works only for your application or maybe
we have Primitives which are now
becoming Global maybe they are Global
for the operating system so they are
typically named mutexes or named
semaphores or whatever else or maybe we
are just using even something different
for instance Cloud lock to synchronize
between clouds or between machines
around the world okay so the important
part around that is well obviously those
global locks they are much slower
depending whether we are talking about
inter process logs this is just a bit
slower however if we're talking about
cross machine locks well they are way
way slower so we need to keep that in
mind and we need to understand that if
we want to get the high highest possible
performance then we should avoid that
then there is a fancy bag around that
this example actually shows you how you
should be patient and careful when you
are reading stack Overflow ever heard
about stack Overflow yeah okay so if you
want to have a like a global lock for a
dll if you Google something like this
and and go obviously it shows you a
stack Overflow answer which tells you
well do this something like dll get good
yeah and this answer was wrong
a meaning wrong in this sense that it
wasn't getting a unique identifier but
something which was pre-compiled and a
common value and then two different
applications from two completely
different developers implemented exactly
the same code snippet from stack
Overflow and someone was tweeting on on
Twitter about that that hey if you
installed this application and like
everything got crashed to deadlock or
whatever he started debugging both of
them because the guy was a programmer
and he found out yep they are using the
same code from stack Overflow so
generally if you're coughing blindly we
never do that obviously but if you
happen to see someone doing that keep in
mind that well those things may actually
cause multiple problems from distant
applications it's not only that you are
affecting your business code but maybe
someone else's code as well moving on
when we need to go with truly Global
locks so locks between machines they
need to be discoverable in some way so
they need to be named they need to have
like a global unique identifiers or some
well-known names or some well-known
patterns and they typically require
network communication so notice how fast
we were before and how slow we are
getting now how long does it take to get
from Australia to let's say the United
States and I mean about the wire now but
about the plane and if you can't like
calculate the speed of light and how
many kilometers it is from here to there
you'll quickly realize that just one
single round trip will take you tens and
hundreds of milliseconds one round trip
and if we are talking about getting a
lock between multiple machines then we
are probably talking about like
two-phase Comet which has what four
round trips you go there and ask hey can
you do this yep I can okay do this here
if I did that we have four round trips
lovely and and then what and we are now
talking about like hundreds of
milliseconds that's why distributed logs
will kill your performance immediately
so generally avoid doing that and only
use them if you are know what you're
doing if you know what you're doing and
if you are sure that's the that's the
right solution
now we come to some problems with locks
well there are multiple things when what
happens when something dies if we are
running inside a critical section and we
die is it safe to proceed how do we know
if it's safe to proceed how do we know
if we died if we are running a semaphore
we don't know that but if we are just
running a lock in between machine sorry
not between machines between multiple
applications on the same machine how do
we know whether the other threat in this
other machine this other application
died or not because we don't get an
exception right we may not get an
exception not get enough notification
how do we check who owns the lock to
just ping that guy how do we know if we
are talking about multiple machines that
the other guy died and is not like
running super slow or maybe our internet
connection got super slow and we just
cannot reach the other end right how do
we get to that and the most important
thing if there was one sentence you
remember memorized from this talk it's
this one always acquire your locks with
timeouts this can be crazy high timeout
something like 24 hours right because
our process is finishing milliseconds so
24 hours seems like should never happen
and then one day you might be surprised
that it does never acquire a log without
the timeout which means actually you
might now fit might now think if you are
c-sharp developers and most of you are
about two things you use commonly in
your code base first of them being lock
keyword how do you put a timeout in lock
keyword does this word support the
timeout and second more importantly
because how many of you ever use lock
like this year
okay a couple of hands how many of you
ever used a weight this year ah how do
you put a timeout in a weight and this
is exactly the same issue if you are
using async in a weight you are risking
you have a timeout and like you deadlock
and you have no time out inside the wait
so well that look will just be there
think about that when you are writing
your code and now we come to the
question okay logs seem to be terrible
this goddess stage is telling us well
this is worst thing what can we do
instead we can use uh and we'll just
briefly touch on it there is an
operation which is like not considered
to be locking operation which is called
compar and swap cast for short and this
comparing swap operation does something
like this code snippet on the left which
basically is taking a lock then getting
some value from the memory comparing it
to the new value we would like to have
stored in the memory and if this value
was as we expected to be then we
override it and then we just return
where is it useful and how can this be
useful well instead of doing a lock and
going with something we can now return
to this issue we had in like one of the
first slide which was variable plus plus
okay we can now do this explicitly read
the variable value increment it in our
CPU registers and now call compare and
swap operation so this operation will do
this we'll do go and say hey if the
value in the memory is still this which
we read then please override it with
this value which we have here and this
will be done atomically meaning it
either succeeds or fails and CPUs will
take care of making sure that it doesn't
break anything and we can just use it
without holding the lock potentially we
need to do this in a loop meaning that
because if the value was changed in the
meantime then we just repeat this
operation okay over and over again but
this way we are avoiding logs and if we
are going with log free programming then
obviously this is the like the most
important primitive for lock free code
and there are multiple instructions for
instance on x86 so CPUs probably most of
you use it's CMP exchange okay so this
is supported by the operating not by the
operating system itself but the by the
CPU itself and exposed to for instance
in.net business class interlocked
compare exchange so this is how we do
that to avoid logs and based on that we
build more and more sophisticated
concurrency Primitives now getting down
to some real life scenarios so where can
things really go wrong even though we
might not even be using logs at all or
not be aware that we are using them
first thing is finalizers ever seen a
disposable interface I guess you have
okay so now I'm going to show you
something which is first this is a demo
so beware it may fail as with all demos
running out running like life however
this is also something which is a a bit
tricky so first things first
if we are running a finalizer let me get
to a code like this what if we are
running a finalizer so if we are running
any code which implements eye disposable
we should dispose it that's obvious
right but now comes the trick if you do
terminate your application by calling
environment exit or by just clicking x
button in top right corner then.net
platform doesn't guarantee you that it
will call your finalizers but thus lets
you know that it might try calling them
meaning that meaning that when you exit
your application your finalizers may be
called by the.net platform itself okay
not guaranteed that it will be done but
this is possible now what comes now
comes the thing this is like a seemingly
safe piece of code we are just opening
the file stream writing some content to
it and that's it and we are using the
using keywords so it should clear clean
things up right now let's see what might
go wrong if it doesn't break this time
then I have a video showing that so
hopefully we are good so what we are
going to do is we are just running
trying to write a ABC content to the
file and this application runs in stew
mode like the first mode is just
constantly like while true constantly
running itself again and the other mode
we are just trying to print something to
the file so we create two threads one of
them is printing and the other one of
them is terminating the application with
environment exit right so what happens
if we now write a try running this code
we have the content here which is just
ABC okay so this is what we are trying
to write and now let's run it and
because I'm presenting well you might be
seeing the screen flickering right it's
constantly running application in the
background so let's run it for a while
and see if it breaks it did break many
times earlier this morning when I was
trying it but what's going on under the
hood we have two Frets one of them is
printing and using this uh this using
keyword so it will call dispose method
on the stream okay and inside this
dispose method under the hood it will be
flashing the stream down the line so
printing the content to the file okay
but the other thread is terminating the
application and when we are terminating
the application.net might call your
finalizers finalizer might call what
dispose method and then we go to the
file content and Bank there you go we
have ABC ABC it was flashed twice okay
this is something all your apps all
your.net apps well there is a risk you
are doing something like this generally
exiting your application is not trivial
guys it's not just environment.exit
right folks this is much harder than
this so all your applications are
actually multi-threaded by design by
default and you need to deal with that
and more importantly well the question
is is this a bargain.net it's not
because us if you are doing something
like this you should control the
concurrency primitive so in my case the
solution to that was something like this
just let let the garbage collector know
that it should not call the dispose on
my behalf that I'll be doing that on my
own so I'm I'm registering those this
stream and this writer from the garbage
collector so now when someone calls
environment exit it doesn't code that it
doesn't call the uh the dispose method
on the other hand uh today I also
noticed and let's try it again maybe
we'll get similar issue again if you are
doing something like this like double
flush is not the only erroring oh sorry
I just fixed it and I don't want to fix
it the like the the double flash is not
the error you might get the other error
we might get and let's wait for it for a
couple of seconds is actually some
internal document structures may get
broken so sometimes I am getting a
completely different exception here
let's see if we got it telling that it
tried to obtain some safe handle from
the windows platform operating system
nope the same error as before but
generally there are multiple issues here
which we are going uh which we might see
so generally this is the first um the
first thingy whenever we are doing any
like finalizers or any uh objects which
need to be disposed be aware that may
break those for you the other exception
we might be getting is a common common
pattern you might have seen at your uni
or anywhere else which is you acquire
the lock then you enter the try block
and try releasing it and finally right
what could go wrong and the answer is if
there is an exception between acquire
and try then you never release this lock
and this is something actually dotnet
solved or because it did have this bug
with your lock keyword it was doing
exactly this before.net 4.5 so they did
have this bug and they fix it now they
this acquire lock is inside the try
block but if you go to other platforms
Java python anywhere else you pretty
often see exactly the same pattern being
shown as the one right pattern to use
and the question is well do you have any
guarantees there will be no exception in
between okay another issue yet another
thing is double check lock so this is
also pattern you probably learned at
your University which seemed to be
amazing right what is the problem with
like initializing a Singleton we entered
the uh the synchronized section or log
section this code comes from java same
can be or same as possible in c-sharp so
we enter the lock lock section and we
check whether our Singleton object is
null if it's now meaning it wasn't
initialized yet okay so we just
initialize it and then we return the
instance problem with that is it's super
slow because every single time we take
this Singleton we want to get this
Singleton instance we are accessing this
log entering the critical section right
so we should avoid that because it's
slow so someone figured out why not
check before entering the critical
section if the object is initialized or
not Sims doable seems possible the
problem is your platform does not
guarantee you that it's some
optimizations down on the CPU level are
allowed to improve the code performance
and your platform specifically jvm in
this case allows you or allows for your
code to first store this new helper
instance inside the helper variable and
then call the Constructor
so with this possible that you already
have the helper like handle to the
object initialized but the object is not
done initializing itself then the other
thread comes in checks if helper is now
it's not okay I'm going I'm going I'm
doing that and use this uninitialized
object dot net seemingly uh like doesn't
tell us that this problem is real in
dotted platform however there is no
guarantee that it's not meaning that we
should be avoiding double check lock and
probably just using lazy from.net
platform if we want to have a single
tone another issue if you are allocating
anything you're like you are allocating
new new object right it's allocated in
the Heap okay and the Heap because it's
used by multiple threads typically needs
to be locked as well so there is a lock
inside your hip okay so when you go new
object.net platform and the operating
system takes the lock so other thread
cannot change the Heap modify the hip
pointers when you are doing that this
means that if you just passed some other
threat or killed some other threat and
that other threat was right in the
middle of allocation then you'd
effectively kill this lock it's acquired
it would never be released okay so what
happens is you will get a deadlock
pretty soon because even seemingly safe
a console.writeline will probably try
allocating some string under the hood
and you'll get a deadlock okay never
kill your threads never even pause your
Frets if you pass some other fret and
then do logger print I paused you you
get a location and you may get an error
okay so multiple platforms deal with
that in multiple ways for instance they
have different hip for different Frets
so each fret has its own hip but
generally you never know what you're
dealing with or maybe you can tell me
how does it work in Python JavaScript C
plus plus on any other language you
probably used last week and if you don't
do not pause your Frets that's the rule
of thumb the other thing is dll main
lock in Windows when you're loading some
new library inside your process space a
lock is being taken meaning that if you
do something like from your main
function which would cause another
Library being loaded then you get a
deadlock okay yet another situation we
probably won't hit that with c-sharp
easily because we very rarely Implement
our own dll main function but this is
pretty common what we were doing with
like regular dlls with C plus and this
lock is pretty pretty common another
example is something touching more like
a Linux or Mac OS or generally Unix
operating systems if you do fork and you
don't do exact you risk another deadlock
how does it work when you have multiple
threads in your application and one of
the thread is forking the process okay
the child process gets only this one
single thread audio other friends which
were running in parent do not get to the
child process when you Fork so if any of
those other threats held a lock then you
get another case for deadlock because
this will lock will never be released in
the child okay so if you fork and then
for instance try printing out hey I did
Fork then what you get is someone might
be taking a look for your hip and you
again get allocation in the middle which
is locked and you get again your then
your deadlock again okay so never call
Fork without exec column being called
immediately after the folk no logging in
between no anything just fork and exec
always
and this one will skip because this is
for counter programming so we'll just
skip that the other things which we are
using is for instance and for instance
SQL databases if we are dealing with SQL
database or any other database it
actually provides two different types of
logs you need to be aware of one of them
is called Latch and this is like the
actual lock primitive SQL Server uses to
protect its own like memory Pages etc
etc but the other kind of lock is the
lock we use for our transactions so the
isolation level heads up if you know
what your isolation level is on your DB
context you are using with your database
what's the default right and there is
there is one hand congrats to the
gentleman the thing is this default
depends on the technology you are using
for instance if you are connecting with
DB context from NTT framework I might be
wrong here but I think it was going with
serialized however it was not okay
apparently I was wrong uh but some other
Technologies were going with not even
with the repeatable read but we've read
committed okay so there are multiple
isolation levels in play and if you
don't know which isolation level you are
dealing with then you may get some
issues did you for instance know that
with read committed isolation level when
you are reading like records from the
table you do select star from table it
may be that it has like multiple rows
then you may read the same row twice
just with read committed this is
something you might get and this is
default for multiple Technologies so if
you are dealing with that well that's
another source of locking issues you may
hit and yet another is any Cloud leases
you are using right if you are accessing
Azure blob skills zookeepers anything
else those things they do use some lock
because they do list those mechanisms
and actually what we need to do is we
need to use timeouts for locking those
things most of them have timeouts by
default meaning that you try acquire
hiring some some resource in the cloud
it will be by default on a lease way so
you need to refresh the list every
minute and this is what we are used to
seems to be okay but there is another
problem what if we took this lease and
we need to refresh it every minute but
we maybe not forget but we are too busy
doing something and we do not refresh it
what if we are like waiting for
something inside our application and it
took a little longer than a minute what
if it's not just taking a look but even
seemingly safe Loop performing some
calculations and we just can't get it
right on time then the lease will be
released okay someone else might come
take the resource acquire it and then we
are doing something believing that we
still own the resource even though we do
not so this is actually quite the
opposite example of what we were talking
before right it's not about we cannot
acquire the log or cannot acquire the
resource forever it's about that we did
acquire it but it was taken out from us
and we are not aware of that keep in
mind you need to refresh your leases
constantly and make sure that you do
that even if you are very busy doing
something else
and ultimately is yet another example of
Lisa's logs concurrency primitive
something which computer science will
never solve for us and this is the
business log we need to take what if we
want to book a ticket for a play for for
a game or whatever right we want to
choose a seed so we book this seat for
15 minutes but what if the the payment
doesn't go through what happens right we
need to release this lock after 15
minutes we need to have those logical
business logs in some way and actually
this is something we should be
considering because if we are now
talking about multiple people coming at
the same time like we open uh booking
tickets like midnight and there is
thousands of people waiting in line just
trying to book a ticket they will just
kill our application not because well we
don't have enough CPU power but because
we are like locking all those seats
right and they then got abandoned and
all that stuff so think about that how
can we solve that on a business level do
we need locks up tall okay so this is
the thingy and now moving on we will
quickly run through algorithms to see
how those things can be implemented on
the hood and then we will get to our
unlock so the first algorithm which is
which was super important for the
computer science is called Deckers
algorithm and it did work did solve the
critical section problem for two for two
processes or for two Frets only it was
later generalized to think code
Patterson's algorithm which is now or
which was able to run on multiple
threads or end Frets and there were
obviously other algorithms
generalizations of these ideas and even
though now we think okay locking a
resource is Trivial what's hard then
right then actually if you read history
of those things it was actually a very
interesting problem and people were
thinking for a long time how do I like
juggle with two variables to log this
resource so these were actual
breakthroughs in the computer science
now how can we reason about locks
because let's say that we have those
logs and now we would like to make sure
that okay do I get them right I need to
use lock I need to use synchronize I
need to use mutexes how do I get them
right and there is obviously multiple
different mathematical approaches for
instance calculus of communicating
systems or sequential process or maybe
Pi calculus typical spaces other things
you can read about them on computer
science Pages this is like University
think but the one which is actually used
like out there in real world is called a
TLA plus so TLA plus source code you see
on your right this is something in which
you basically get your code this could
be C plus plus code C sharp code or
whatever C sharpest code you have and
you translate it to some different
sentence like this one and there are
even like translators which do that
automatically for you and then you have
a solver which is trying to prove all
the assumptions spread conditions and
post conditions and show you that this
code is not correct and for instance AWS
when they are implementing their
dynamodb they do verify correctness of
their locking algorithms with TLA plus
so if you want to make sure that your
code works then unit tests will never
give you that but things like TLA plus
will prove that your code Works prove to
the extent that there are obviously
things like cosmic ray or some inferior
interference from other cables you have
like other wires but generally if we
assume computers do their job right then
you can prove that your algorithms are
correct the other important thing we
need to talk about is caches and memory
model right now if you are trying to
read some memory some value from memory
you are actually never going to the RAM
memory directly never it's all cached by
L1 L2 L3 caches in your CPU okay this
means that if there is a variable in RAM
memory okay and they have two Frets
accessing it it means that now we have
exactly two different copies of the same
variable one in Cache one of CPU one and
the other in Cache of the cpu2 how are
those things synchronized and this is a
thing called messy Illinois protocol so
this protocol code gets its name from
four different states like modified
exclusive shirt and valid and it's
taking care of sharing your memory and
we get another issue with things like
this because we already mentioned that
computers are dealing with much bigger
amount of memory than like just one byte
so imagine what happens if we are
allocating an array of 17 integers and
we create two threads first of them is
trying to constantly modify element at
index 0 of that array and then another
thread is constantly trying to allocate
or modify element at index 1. what can
go wrong with this finger there are two
different Frets two different integers
they should be completely separate the
problem with this is because integers
are four byte long and because those two
integers are next in line they fell into
the same cache line of your CPU which is
64 bytes long nowadays will get longer
probably in near future meaning that
those two integers are constantly
getting to the same cache line so if red
one on cpu1 tries to modify the first
integer then the Fret 2 on cpu2 will
need to synchronize with this CPU one to
ask hey give me your cache line because
you modified it okay so this is way
slower and the solution for that is we
need to implement think called stride so
instead of changing the integer at index
0 here and one here we should be
changing in the integer at index 16. So
This falls into different cache line yet
another source of issue we may get in
our applications uh kernel thinks we
will just skip for now so now the rule
of thumb or the outcome of this whole
discussion is
super tricky to get this right generally
use already available mechanisms which
are there for instance blocking
collection and dotnet task run any
concurrent synchronization or cons or
like a structured concurrency Primitives
executor service MPI other things avoid
building those on your own because there
are multiple layers which can go wrong
other Solutions include event changing
the way you reason about applications do
not Implement things just like that with
threats go with agents go with actors go
with models which actually take care of
that do not Implement your own solution
and what about async you might ask is
there any problem with async well the
problem with async it's not about
concurrency but async actually changes
the world significantly for you because
in async you do not know where is your
continuation running on so if you try
unlocking something and then try
awaiting then hey you may have a problem
because you don't know whether the
continuation which is here is it running
on the same thread of no or not and if
it's not then actually it's different
Fred who owns this lock so compiler
won't let you do that but we can be
smarter than a compiler and why not go
with monitor enter monitor exit right
this obviously compiles and then throws
its exception on you why because you
tried exiting and releasing the lock
from a different thread so if you go
with async all the stuff I just told you
you just can't use it easily but but you
can't use it but all the libraries you
use they do use it because they have no
idea that you're running a in async code
okay so this can break a lot just be
aware of that
and now we'll quickly run through a
couple of custom implementations just to
show you one big lock how implementing a
lock may look like and it gets crazy but
before doing that I told you semaphores
are crazy because they don't let you
know that who owned that and whether
it's abandoned or not instead of using
semaphores you need to go with new
textures okay so the solution for using
semaforce is you get mutexes like an
array of mutexes and you try waiting any
of them in your dotnet application and
then you get the ID of the mutex which
you acquired or you get the exception
with the ID of mutex which was abandoned
so this is probably something you could
be using instead of semaphores because
semaphores are super dangerous just go
with mute access in case the other
example of let's Implement a locking in
like least amount of code we can and
that's it you just use a file you open
the file and you ask operating system
hey please do lock this file for me okay
and this operating system will lock the
file for you and you are good this is
mutex like well working mutex it even
works between multiple machines if you
have like Network file system which
supports locking files and some
implementations do then you can use this
even to like lock between machines
around the globe obviously will be slow
very slow but generally will work and
now let's move on to an actual mutex
okay let's Implement something for you
so if you ever ask operating system like
Linux Windows whatever hey who owns this
mutex those operating systems will never
tell you that there is no way of finding
out who owns the mutex okay and now if
you are dealing with locking something I
told you always acquire a lock with a
timeout
so the timeout passed 24 hours passed
and you realize okay I can't acquire
this mutex because probably some other
ants some other threat some other
process died and I don't know about that
right because I wasn't notified how can
I deal with that and we are going to
implement a mutex with an ownership
tracking so my mutex which will be
capable of telling us who owns it which
Fred and we in which process so we can
later kill that threat kill that
processor just do something fancy in it
okay so that's the idea so how are we
going to implement that uh so we are
going to use uh interlock compare
exchange so Cast Operation compare and
Swap and we are going to we are going to
have one long field 64 bits of memory
which we'll be sharing between threads
and between processes and inside this
one single long we will store a 32 bits
of the process identifier and and then
32 bits of the thread identifier okay so
this is what we store in the memory one
long variable eight octets storing both
process ID and the thread ID and the
magic is we'll just show you how long it
takes it's something like 200 lines of
code to implement all of that and what
we are doing is first we get this
identifier of ourselves I check my
process ID my thread ID I create an F
value I calculate for how long I should
be trying to acquire this lock and then
throwing exception telling hey I cannot
get this you deal with that I open a
memory mapped file so I open shared
memory between threads between processes
inside the operating system I get
obviously dangerous get handle I need to
get an actual pointer for that memory
and what I'm doing now is I'm spin
looping and I'm trying to do compare and
swap operation on this memory so I
assume if the variable is set to zero
it's zeroed out meaning that the lock is
not acquired it's free to be taken okay
so I told the operating system hey
please try doing that use this memory
and if the memory is still zero then
please store my identifier so my process
ID my thread ID inside this memory and
return me the current value of the
memory okay and this thingy will be done
atomically without synchronizing
anything around etc etc and then I check
okay if the lock was Zero before I came
then it means I now acquired it I can do
my action which is my Lambda which I
pass here which is basically anything I
want to do with this lock okay but if it
wasn't zero then now I have the current
owner of this lock I can extract the the
the holder of the thread ID of the owner
the process ID of the owner and I can do
magic with it I can now start getting
process ID and well if it fails I ignore
the exception here because I'll just
carry on if it doesn't exist I am trying
to clear the lock because if the process
died in the middle well I'm trying to
clear the lock so it's usable now okay
so I'm using comparent swap again but in
the meantime someone might have changed
this thingy so I cannot lock again and
cannot just clear it out because I will
release someone else's lock so I
shouldn't be doing that but if it does
exist then I check if it's not running
for too long I call it self healing time
so I let it like 30 minutes to run if
you're holding this lock for more than
30 minutes then I'm terrible person I'm
trying to well kill you okay so I go
there and I try you know getting the the
process ID then I'm trying to run cdb to
dump a memory of it so get a memory dump
so I know what was happening in that
process probably it had some deadlocking
scenario so I want to debug it later and
then what I'm doing at the very end is
I'm just killing this thingy okay after
killing it finally I spin loop again
come back to the beginning of this Loop
and try acquiring this lock again if
something broke in the middle there is
an issue obviously so we log it and
there is also an in trying interesting
thing that I might be at some point
trying to release this lock which I was
not the owner of meaning that something
really bad happened because I took the
lock I believed I'm the owner and don'ts
happened that someone took this lock
away from me and I'm not the owner of
this one okay so if you get to this line
you have another probably 200 lines of
code figuring out how to fix that right
so this is how you do this thingy
obviously it's not trivial and there are
multiple other with this We There are
multiple other issues with that there is
no furnace right if multiple threats are
trying to acquire this lock there is no
queue who should be the first one to
take it okay so we may starve other
processes taking memory dump of some
other process
while super useful it's also super risky
why because when to take memory dump you
need to have a debugger connect to that
process what if debugger dies then you
can't even kill this process because
it's protea operating system who
protects it now so this is the way how
to create a process which cannot be
terminated at all just attach debugger
to it and don't let debugger like or
kill the debugger okay so ideally we are
also we are doing a spin weight here so
we are hugging the CPU like hundred
percent of the usage like crazy
obviously but it just works so that's a
proof of concept kinda but I'm using
this in production as well with some
other Tunes the other thing is I am
storing 32 bits of the identifiers right
what if the process ID is a little
bigger than this right we should store
128 bits like 64 bits of process ID 64
bits of Fred ID right but then we need
to have a CPU support for comparent swap
operation of 128 bits and this is
something you your CPUs may not support
out of the box meaning that this
approach won't work with such a big
amount of memory again another issue
here is we do not support re-entrancy at
all so if I try getting this log and
then try getting this lock again then
it's re-entrancy and what should I do
well I can assume okay I have this log
so I can take it again right but then
how do you track the count how many
times you you got this lock you need to
because you cannot have more than 64
bits with this approach and you need to
atomically have more than 64 bits so you
get you know chicken and egg problem
however generally approach like this
works so this is how you can see how to
implement your sort of user land locking
Primitives which do the which which do
work for you
summary
avoid blocks when possible use some
other things like tasks like executor
services like generally fret pools like
blocking collections you think which
things which are implemented for you in
the starter Library obviously you may
still have issues with those for
instance a friend of mine when we were
at the uni like 10 years ago he found an
issue in concurrent dictionary and
reported that it was fixed got fixed
obviously but we just don't know how
many applications got a problem because
of that concurrent dictionary not
working properly so generally those
things may be broken this is like normal
but use them as much as possible instead
of writing your own logs right another
thing you keep your critical sections
keep your like resource leases keep your
any synchronization Primitives as short
as possible because if you make them
longer then first you decrease the
performance second you risk that you die
in the middle and if you die in the
middle there is a problem because as
State consistent or not think about that
from the business perspective as well
also when you're refreshing cloudleases
make sure you do refresh them on time
and you do not get blocked for any
particular reason think about situations
when you call some external application
while holding a lock because you don't
know what this external application is
doing and how long it will take for it
to finish avoid semaphores they are
nasty obviously that's not like a
official production ready rule of thumb
you would have probably multiple use
cases where some efforts are just good
but be aware of them that they may post
some issues it caused some issues for
you and if you are going with async keep
in mind async brakes locking Primitives
a lot this is probably not an issue for
you if you are using just a c-sharp code
but once you start doing interrupts be
invoke calling maybe some code which is
not async enabled like code from even
vb.net right or maybe some C plus plus
code give keep in mind those things are
not aware of your async enabled code and
may use those locking Primitives and
you'll get them broken by that
and being all of that said it's time to
ask questions and we are shortly after
time so we'll probably take this offline
couple of resources for you are also at
the very end of this slide that if you
are interested in Reading More and being
all of that said and also some like
links to the internet if you don't fancy
reading books and being all of that said
there is a QR code for the slides and
I'd like to thank you for coming to this
talk hope you enjoyed it hope you liked
it have a great afternoon and thank you